public health emergency is in effect in
New York City this morning in response
to the rapidly growing measles outbreak
according to the CDC there have now been
465 measles cases in the US this year
across 19 states now that is the
second-highest number of cases since
measles was declared eliminated in 2000
the disease can spread in areas where
groups of people are unvaccinated tonita
copal is in Brooklyn where measles cases
are popping up within ultra-orthodox
Jewish communities Tony good morning
good morning just a couple years ago
there were only a handful of measles
cases in all of New York City now there
have been more than 250 in just the past
seven months including five patients
sent into intensive care New York City
officials now taking action hoping to
stem that crisis before it gets any
worse
we cannot allow this dangerous disease
to make a comeback here in New York City
we have to stop it now New York City
Mayor Bill de Blasio says he is
determined to defend his city from the
largest measles outbreak in the country
on Tuesday he issued a public health
emergency demanding all people over the
age of six months who live or go to
school in parts of Williamsburg to get
vaccinated or face $1,000 fine according
to the CDC the measles vaccine can be up
to 97% effective measles vaccine works
it is safe it is effective it is time
tested but in the highly concentrated
Orthodox communities of Williamsburg
some parents refuse it's against my
personal religious beliefs this mother
of five says none of her children are
vaccinated and all had measles in the
last month I cannot agree to a
systematic way of just altering the new
system and testifying to God's
imperfection there's no no religious
obligation not to do it just but rabbi
david Niederman who works in brooklyn
says the Torah requires people to not
put others at risk health is the most
important thing and therefore there's no
justification to not to vaccinate just
the opposite mayor de Blasio's
declaration could face legal challenges
last month in Rockland County New York
Executive Edie de declared a state of
emergency
banning
on vaccinated children from public
places but a judge overruled him saying
the outbreak did not rise to the level
of an epidemic day is now appealing that
judge's decision and announced new
orders on Tuesday to keep on vaccinated
children home this outbreak is an
imminent threat to a public health you
have to be not be paying attention do
not understand that
by contrast the measles vaccine is
considered safe and effective by every
major medical body here in the u.s. here
in New York religious schools and
daycares are being told to keep on
vaccinated children out of the classroom
or they could face closure Anthony now a
lot of concern in New York schools about
the measles outbreak Tony thank you